ray dalio welcome to sway hi glad to be
here so last time we talked was your
first book which was a big fat book that
could kill a poodle if you threw it on
it talk a little bit what what made you
do this book
well i learned
a long time ago
that uh events that surprised me were
many cases things that didn't happen in
my lifetime before
for example 2008 financial crisis i
understood that
only because i said the great depression
in other words i needed to go before my
lifetimes in order to understand them
so three big things
are happening in our lifetime that never
happened before and those three things
most importantly they are the main
drivers of our existence today so let's
go through them because this isn't
effectively a book about how economic
empires rise and fall
so can you distill the argument i know
it's an entire book but talk about these
three things and the big cycle and where
the us is within it okay and then by the
way it's not economic you can't separate
economics from politics 100 never could
so it's a rise in decline of empires and
it's about world power and money right
so the three things are first about
money
the creation of an enormous amount of
debt and the monetizing that that means
the printing of money
to
when you don't have enough money and you
want to have more buying power
all countries through history create
this debt and they monetize it and that
has an impact if it has an inflationary
impact that we're experiencing now it
has an impact on the value of money okay
so that's number one
connected to that is number two that i
never saw in my lifetime this way is the
amount of internal conflict we have the
largest wealth gap we have the largest
income gap and we are having the largest
political gaps since 1900 and so
democracy is not working for us in the
way it did and what we're having is
populism of the right and populism of
the left and irreconcilable differences
in ways that never existed in my
lifetime but happened many times before
many times before in our history um and
the third is the rising of a great power
to challenge the existing great power
and the existing world order
these world orders always happen for the
same reason there are irreconcilable
differences there's a war
somebody wins the war some group wins
the war they've got the power they set
the rules they carve up the world they
have the reserve currency and then you
go a while and then another power comes
and rises and challenges that power and
then they have a war or somebody's got
to determine the rules and then you have
tend to have a conflict and so we have
these three things happening and when
those three things happen together which
is the last time was the 1930-45 period
but you can go back in history and you
could see the right reason countries
rise and decline and i'd what i wanted
to do was to measure these things so i'm
not looking at them subjectively right
so this is polarization political
polarization money a free money policy
essentially and the rise of china is in
this case correct china and its allies
and the united states and its allies and
so we are now seeing that
clarify as to who's aligned with whom